Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're tackling the question
what if our dogs died?
Oh really, why we gotta--
Oh it's a downer.
So sad.
Actually, we had a scare with Jade.
I will say she is fine.
And we had a scare with
Barbara incidentally.
And when I told you I wanted
to talk about a scare,
I didn't tell you what
the scare was to save it
for the podcast.
That's how we live our lives.
And then you're gonna
tell me about your scare
with Barbara so just based on knowing
that we both had scares,
I think we will unpack the
imminent death of our dogs.
Don't--
Not like,
well, imminent's not the right word.
That seems like it's rapidly approaching.
Here's the thing, did you read The Secret?
You ever read The Secret?
I've never read it but
lots of people have.
Did you slide it to me
on a sheet of paper?
No.
Here's The Secret.
And I think if you believe
the things that are written
in The Secret, and Oprah
endorsed it so it must be true,
then you, if you say
things that can happen,
so you just said imminent
death of our dogs
and now you've got me repeating it.
Are you saying we're speaking--
We're manifesting it.
Manifesting.
So we need to unmanifest that.
The immortality of our dogs.
I would like to retract,
yeah the--
The immortality of our dogs.
Immortality of our dogs,
our dogs will live forever.
Our dogs will never
die, our dogs are safe.
Our dogs will never die.
All dogs die but--
Manifest that, Oprah.
Not all dogs truly live.
By the way anytime Oprah
would like to come on,
she is welcome.
We don't do guests anymore, man.
We'd do anything for Oprah.
But would we?
I would.
Would you execute Barbara
for Oprah?
Hmm.
Again, that's not--
That's not the question.
I would do anything for
Oprah but I wouldn't do that.
Oh gosh and you know,
Meatloaf, that's his song.
Never got into Meatloaf but
someone almost bought me
a Meatloaf record which is the other thing
I wanna talk about, well
I'll take a step back
and say I need to unpack my 41st birthday.
I wanna do that in this episode.
I know you're interested
in how I celebrated.
I dove down deep into the birthday hole
and I came out, 41.
Came out 41.
How's it feel?
I've been there for awhile.
So I'll also give you an update on that
even though you were at the
party, Rhett, I don't wanna--
I can give you my
perspective on the party.
I can give a party-goer's perspective
on your 41st birthday party.
Okay, okay.
So we're gonna kinda catch
up with each other, again,
the thing that we're ultimately--
But the dog--
Gonna center on is the
immortality of our dogs and if
for some reason they turn out
to not be as immortal as
we think that they are
and we manifest in Oprah's
name then how would we respond?
And we will tell the stories
of their near deaths.
Which I have not heard yours,
you haven't heard mine.
No that's right but what do
you wanna talk about first
because I got another--
I thought you had like--
I got a little thing that I'm working on
that I just wanna process.
You have a project?
It's summertime.
Is it a Popsicle fort?
I think you--
Because remember when
we made the Popsicle fort growing up?
Yeah yeah yeah.
And you--
This was a church project.
You remember when they took that room,
the small room upstairs
in Buies Creek for--
It was dedicated to a Popsicle fort.
And the only thing in
there was a Popsicle fort.
It's pretty awesome.
And you were so proud
of it and I would go in
and disassemble it on a regular basis.
I was wondering who did that.
And be like it doesn't need that,
we don't need that tower.
That's not what I was
gonna talk about.
Oh I'm sorry.
You said you had a project,
I thought it might be a Popsicle fort.
I don't know if it's
technically summertime.
I don't know when this
comes out but to my mind,
we're in summertime because--
For sure we are.
My kids are out of
school, that's summertime.
We're in summertime as this
is being recorded, man.
June 21st I think is the
technical first day of summer.
Which is our first day of tour.
I don't go by official stuff like that.
But when the kids got out of school,
when the traffic gets a little lighter
in LA it becomes summertime,
you start to think,
what am I gonna do different?
What am I gonna do different?
Yeah, shave my beard a little bit shorter.
This morning--
Summer beard.
6/24--
Oh.
Is the release date of this.
Welcome to summer.
When's summer?
The summer solstice.
See I was right, so I'm thinking of ways
that I can embrace summer
and so this morning,
I thought I'd try something
new on for size literally.
Do you have it on right now?
Yeah.
It's down here.
See that?
Look at, see my shoes?
Only you can see it, Rhett.
Not even the YouTube viewers can see it.
It's just a normal shoe.
Yeah, but look down at the edge.
You see down in the shoe,
what's down in that shoe?
I honestly can't see into the shoe.
My foot's in the shoe.
Yeah but what else is in the shoe?
Nothing.
Oh you're sockless.
I'm going sockless today
because I walked out,
these shoes are down there at my garage,
but I gotta do some
planning to put my socks on
up in my bedroom.
If there's no socks, sometimes
I'll take my socks off
when I take my shoes off
and I'll come into the house
either in bedroom slippers.
Like a '50s dad sitcom dad.
Put on my bedroom slippers,
or I'll just be barefoot.
But I guess yesterday I
didn't take off my socks
from my shoes, I put 'em
in the laundry upstairs.
Sorry if this is too detailed but then
when I came down today,
I assumed there would be old socks there
that I could just reuse.
There weren't and I
was like you know what,
I'm doing it.
But you know why you--
It's summertime.
No, but you know why you did this.
I'm going sockless.
We had a conversation about the fact that
I've been wearing shoes without socks.
I knew you were gonna say this.
I knew you were gonna
say that yesterday we had
a conversation about it and
you were gonna take credit.
Again, not a sponsor.
You're gonna put your
shoe up on the table.
I've got these shoes--
I got coffee up here man.
It's not anywhere near you.
These shoes don't require--
Fleas are probably
jumpin' off the freakin'--
They don't require socks
and I'm not even gonna
mention what they are.
If they wanna be a sponsor,
then we'll talk about 'em extensively.
Yeah we talked about it.
You see the ads on Instagram,
then you buy the shoes
and I looked at the ads--
But these are designed to not have socks.
Your shoes are not designed to have socks.
I'm not saying you have
to buy these shoes,
I'm just saying that you can't do that.
I think you did influence me.
Of course.
Because I'm like,
I've always wanted to
wear shoes without socks.
They don't feel good though.
It always feels like it should feel good
and I see people who
do it and I'm envious,
I'm like man.
You should try these on.
That person's trottin' around sockless.
It must be summertime, it must be spring,
it must be fall.
It could be any time of year
but you just seem freer,
and I'm envious of that.
Yeah you should be.
And I'm like I can't do that
'cause of the foot sweat.
Well how do you feel at this point,
middle of the afternoon?
Not good at all.
Yeah it's a bad idea.
Within five minutes of puttin' 'em on,
I walk out to the car--
Yeah.
And I was like I gotta turn around,
I gotta go all the way upstairs
and I gotta fetch socks.
You make it seem like
you live in a mansion
that it's gonna take a
significant amount of time
to get upstairs.
It would take you 17 seconds
to get to your bedroom.
Well I mean there's 14 steps, man.
Yeah.
That's at least
17 seconds just to get up the stairs.
In a safe manner.
You move pretty slow.
I do three steps at a time,
I'm a long-legged beast.
Anyway, it's not working.
I just wanna be one of
those people so bad.
And my 15 year old son who is not a dork--
Okay he's cooler than you.
And also he knows
what's cool, he wears the cool stuff.
He likes 'em?
I said what do you think
about these, he's like, they look good.
If Kanye come out with these exact shoes,
you would think they were awesome.
I think those look good
but you can't wear 'em without socks.
What is that--
They actually
don't stink though.
Well it's day one.
What are those called,
what's the name of those?
adidas I-5923s.
Smell of it.
No, I don't need to--
Smell it.
No no I don't need to.
I smell of yours.
I'd smell of Oprah's shoes.
I smell of yours on that video we made.
I bet ya Oprah doesn't wear socks.
Do you feel like you would
sweat in normal shoes
but not those?
I would sweat like crazy--
And you don't sweat?
There's no way you don't sweat.
It's just wicked away or something.
Bingo, it's called moisture wicking.
It's constantly being wicked, man.
If you're being wicked--
How do you feel?
You don't think about the sweat.
Do you feel freer because--
I feel like I'm
being wicked constantly.
My feet are just a constant wick.
Now I have in fact--
Translate that into pleasure.
Well I've got a new movie coming out,
John Wick 4.
I don't know what, I'm just
asking what positive benefits
do you receive from
having your feet wicked?
Because I feel like I
know that they're there,
I just can't articulate it.
One less step in the morning,
I thought you would appreciate that.
Yeah.
Extreme comfort.
And I think, I think
showing a little ankle
is a little bit sexy.
Yeah you wear no-show
socks, that's what I do.
But the problem with the
no-show socks is that
they bind, they're so tight on my toes.
You gotta get the right brand.
I picked up some no-show socks--
Well since this whole
opening sounds like an ad,
let's go ahead and talk
about no-show socks.
No no, yeah, so I picked
up some no-show socks.
Is it all-doe or Al-doe?
Aldo, that place the shoe store, Aldo?
I think it's Aldo.
Al-doe.
And there were my--
Al-doe you go dere,
you don't know how to say it.
Well my brother was in town
and we went in there for something
and I got ones that they,
this is a really good price,
it was like three pairs
for 11 bucks which is--
Is this whole podcast a commercial?
This isn't a commercial.
Don't get offended.
Talking about products that
you are enjoying in life
and then talking crap about them
is definitely not a commercial.
This is a warning if anything.
If you have size 12 feet--
Oh you don't like 'em.
Don't get the Aldo socks that
they sell for a good price
'cause the things were
so tight that literally,
I bought three pairs in a pack.
You lost a toe.
Every single pair and listen, I'm talkin',
I got trimmed toenails.
It wasn't my toenails bustin' through.
I trim my toenails on a regular basis now
'cause I never know when I'm gonna show up
and they're gonna be like,
we need to show your feet
on camera today.
Really like--
You are bitter today.
No I'm not bitter, I'm very happy.
I watched seven hours
of Oprah right before,
I was on the Oprah channel.
Anyway, my toe busted
through the sock in one day.
By the afternoon I get
home, I take my shoe off
and my toes have busted
through but if you get just,
I don't even know what brand it is
'cause this is not a commercial
but I got some on Amazon.
Those have lasted forever
and they also have
this little thing that
grips the back of your foot,
those little rubber things.
Yeah yeah I got some
of those but they're still tight.
Yeah you gotta size up.
Get the XL.
Talkin' about
your toe bustin' through,
check this out.
Yeah you busted through
your whole thing.
These shoes, look at that.
My toe busted through,
my big toe busted through
the end of my right shoe.
In the first week
that you owned them.
Yeah after a week of wearing
these but I liked 'em so much
I bought another pair anyway.
Is that the other pair?
No, this is, the new
pair didn't bust through.
I wore these without socks
'cause I was not about
to wear my go-to shoes and funk 'em up.
This was an experiment, man.
adidas would have replaced
those, by the way.
No charge.
I know but you have to complain.
And time is money, complaint
is time and time is money.
And good.
I spent that time just ordering
another pair of shoes, ironically.
So is your project that
you were talking about
you not wearing socks?
Bingo.
Two can play bingo.
Okay that's it huh?
Huh?
Well I didn't say
that it was some, I
didn't think it was worthy
of a opening conversation but
it looks like we've had it.
No, I'm just saying that I wanna know
if I should press on.
No not if they don't wick.
Because does it give you that reggae vibe?
Like all of a sudden you're laid-back?
If it does not wick, you musta quit.
That doesn't work.
If it does not wick, you must sock it.
If it does not wick, you must not commit.
Yeah you don't have wicking shoes, man.
You can't do it, you gotta put socks on.
If you're interested in some
wicking shoes just ask me,
I'll tell you where I got these.
Let's get into more weighty matters.
Speaking of wicking...
We're selling no-show socks
that are the right size--
No no no.
And we're selling--
That hat wicks.
adidas--
I don't think the hat wicks
but let's act like the
hat wicks for this ad.
Yeah this hat wicks.
That hat wicks.
It's a wicking hat.
That hat wicks
your moisture that comes out of your head.
If you've got head moisture problems
then this hat is perfectly
designed for that.
It'll wick it right away and
send it to the atmosphere.
It's also camouflage and
has an orange emblem.
I've never used the
word emblem on anything
that we talked about, you should say logo.
What's wrong with using the word emblem?
So deer season's coming up in the fall.
In the fall.
Why did your voice get nasal?
Deer season's coming up in the fall
if you wanna wear that hat
because the deer cannot see the orange.
But the hunters can.
The hunters can.
Is that why hunters wear orange
because only hunters can see it?
Deer hunters wear orange
because they don't wanna be shot
by other hunters.
Yes, bingo.
And the deer are color blind
and so it all just blends in.
Hold on--
But the reason that
it's camouflage orange
is because it breaks up
the visual pattern which
still serves as camouflage
because it breaks up the lines.
That's why it's orange camo.
I've never thought, honestly,
I thought it was --
You thought they were attracting
deer with orange clothes?
No, I just thought that they had,
they were just taking one for the team.
As a disadvantage.
It was like I'm willing
to wear orange to not get
shot by another hunter
even though it makes me
more visible to deer.
For some reason I've
thought that's how it works.
And if you're hunting dove--
And hold on,
are you true this?
Are you truing this?
Okay let me just say--
Do you actually know or are you BSing?
Well let me just put it this way,
I have known this since I was a child.
But that may not
make it right, it just means I've grown up
in the culture of North
Carolina, a hunting culture,
knowing this to be true but
I've never fact-checked it.
You've assumed it.
I think it's true.
And I don't know why.
I will readily admit--
'Cause some redneck told me.
It's a stupid assumption.
All right, Jacob has pulled up a fact.
Deer are essentially red-green
colorblind like some humans.
Their color vision is
limited to short blue
and middle green wavelength color.
What about orange?
That means they can't see orange
and that's why you can wear it.
However, you can't, in fact--
Then it's stupid for
hunters to not wear orange.
Why are there so many hunters--
Let me get this out.
It's the law.
You have to wear orange if you hunt deer.
If you don't, it's illegal, okay?
That is the law in most
states or all states
where you hunt deer.
The second thing is one time--
But I've seen hunters
not wearing orange.
Yeah.
Let me just finish the damn sentence, man.
It's more than one sentence.
The point--
It's multiple sentences.
My dad used to take us dove hunting.
Told you that you're bitter today.
I was in a good mood, man,
but you won't let me talk.
Deer cannot see blaze orange the same way
that humans can see it.
It likely appears brown or gray to deer.
But we gotta ask a deer to know.
Now--
Please finish your sentence.
The reason that you see
hunters not wear orange
is because they're bird
hunters and birds like dove
can see orange, in fact,
one of the times my dad,
we took a guy hunting with us growing up.
We never hunted deer, we hunted
dove, the symbol of peace.
And this guy who came
along in the group wore
an orange shirt and my dad was like,
what the hell are you doing, man?
You can't wear orange,
it's not deer hunting.
The doves see orange.
They've got better sight than we do.
So ironically, did he shoot him?
So he killed a guy and
then we went hunting.
It made it easier to get shot at
'cause he was wearing orange.
Huh, the birds.
Hmm.
That makes sense and
that's why I was construing
all hunters together
and assuming that the ones
who wear orange are just safer.
Yeah.
But they're hunting
different things.
Yeah exactly.
If I'd have let you talk,
I would have learned that.
Yeah.
This is a bonus
for the video.
Mythical.store.
Deer aren't gonna see this but birds are.
But that's not--
And I'm talking about
the emblem that I'm pointing at.
I don't think that's legal though.
It's gotta be predominantly orange.
I don't think you can just
have an orange emblem.
Whoa, did you see that?
I sunk all the way down.
'Cause I hit, my foot is now
caught under my chair, woo.
Sorry.
Do you wanna start talking about the dogs
or do you wanna work towards the dogs?
Because I kinda feel like we
should work towards the dogs.
Because we're gonna talk about--
I'll give an update on my birthday.
The emotional quotient.
Yeah 'cause I mean
turning 40 was a big deal,
we both had big parties, you can go back
and listen to those
respective Ear Biscuits
about those two events.
41 does not warrant that big of an event.
41 does not warrant an
entire podcast conversation.
So it's not getting one.
And it ain't gonna get it.
Basically it just warrants the fact that
if you were already having a get-together,
it was like a standing event every month,
you got a game night,
then basically, a lot
of our friends come to.
I'm not gonna say every
single one of my friends.
You commandeered my game
night as your birthday party.
Jessie graciously texted and said, "Hey,
"our next game night
falls on Link's birthday."
Yep.
"So you guys wanna do
that as his birthday?
"It's totally up to you,"
and I was like yeah,
that's a good idea.
I didn't mind at all.
You were hurt?
You a little hurt by that?
No it's fine.
I brought my games over to your house.
We didn't--
Jessie was flying out
of town by the way so it actually helped.
We didn't play any of the
games and you still have 'em.
Well I'll get to that.
I left my games there.
I'll get to that, would
you just let me talk
about my birthday?
So yeah, I was very appreciative to,
basically we already
had an invitation list,
everybody was already
expecting to show up somewhere,
it made it very simple.
So they come over and I was
like well, you know what,
the one thing about a birthday
party if I'm gonna have one,
even if it is just 41,
I kinda would like presents.
This is me talkin' to Christy.
This is not an adult thing to say.
Christy's like--
This isn't what
41 year old men do--
Yeah we'll invite
people over and I'm
gonna say they don't have
to bring gifts, I was like whoa whoa,
hold on, let's discuss.
I'm like I kinda would like gifts.
You know what but I'm gonna
make it easy and affordable--
Unreal.
For people.
Honestly what I'd really
like is records to add
to my record collection.
And your wife--
Just give me a used record.
You can get one for like four
bucks, it can be an expression
of what you as my friend--
Well no hold on.
Think I would like.
You're taking
what you said you--
This is what I told her.
You weren't there.
Well your wife sent
an email out, okay, and
your wife made it sound like
it was her idea, what she said was--
Oh yeah?
Is that, you know what,
you don't have to bring a gift but--
She took one for the team I think.
She made it tactful which is something
that you are not about to do.
Right.
She said, "You don't have to bring a gift,
"but if you do bring a
gift, he's always looking
"to beef up his record collection."
Right.
That's a paraphrase.
I don't think your wife
used the term beef up.
I don't think I've ever
heard her say that.
Yeah.
But you know what I'm--
'Cause I am beefed up.
Right.
You're already beefed up,
she doesn't need to say--
She doesn't say you need to beef up.
Sometimes she'll say, "I've
noticed that you're maintaining
"your beefed up."
Or staying beefed up--
Did you notice
when you showed up, you
were one of the first people
to show up because you're my best friend.
Yeah I showed up first.
You gotta be there to help.
I showed up first and by the way,
didn't get you used
records and didn't get you,
I got you like six records.
That's right.
I spent like $200
on records.
I did notice that.
For your birthday.
Just so you know.
I'll have to post, if you
wanna know what my records are,
you have to follow me on
Instagram, @linklamont.
Lots of shout-outs.
I'll share a few of 'em.
Did you notice when you
said that it reminded me
of The Golden Girls theme song.
Which goes, how does it begin?
If you tell me the beginning, I know,
how does it start?
What did I say that makes you think--
Golden Girls theme song.
Of the theme song?
♪ Thank you for being a friend ♪
♪ Travel down the road and back again ♪
♪ Your heart is true, you're
a pal and a confidant ♪
♪ And if you threw a party ♪
Oh.
♪ And invited everyone you knew ♪
♪ You would see ♪
The greatest gift, yeah.
♪ The greatest gift would be for me ♪
From me.
♪ You would see the greatest
gift would be from me ♪
♪ And the card attached would say ♪
♪ Thank you for being a friend ♪
And you know what, you did attach a card.
But it said happy birthday.
It did.
And it had Jessie from Breaking Bad on it.
♪ And you would see the
greatest gift would be from me ♪
♪ And the card attached would say ♪
♪ Happy birthday ♪
You had a sweet note
inside which I'll treasure.
It did, it was very sweet.
And I'll only keep to myself.
'Cause people complained--
I was mostly interested
in the records though.
But people complained.
Let me just say this, people complained
about my birthday wish to you
on the internet.
Instagram?
Not being--
Sappy enough.
Sappy, I saw that, I think I was--
It was funny this year.
That was me, man.
He's 41, guys.
I have fan accounts
of myself--
No one cares.
And I commented as if
I were a fan of myself.
I got sappy at 40, I'll get sappy at 50.
Right.
The next nine years,
you're gonna have to just
deal with mild comedy.
You put some of that in the
card and I appreciate it.
Again it's not for public
consumption and I do take issue--
Make it sound like, I didn't
say anything embarrassing.
It wasn't like a sext or anything.
I mean your wife wrote on one side,
you wrote on the other side.
Yeah.
You wrote on the left side so it felt like
you wrote yours first.
I did.
So you didn't write anything
that would have been
really awkward if she read it,
I'll put it to you that way.
I don't think there's anything
that I could have written
that if she had have
happened to open the card,
not planning on writing in it
that would have been awkward.
A sext would fall in that category.
Yeah but I don't think
I've got that in me.
That's what she said.
Gosh.
Jacob.
Just, he's just shaking his head.
Listen, so,
I don't know if you know this but
I met everybody at the door--
Took the records from them.
I took the record
and they would--
Hold on.
And it would be wrapped and
I would immediately unwrap it
'cause I was, I was very interested in--
And might I say that one of our friends
brought you records and
you gave them, you said,
"I got all these," and
gave 'em right back to him.
I felt bad, this was Ward.
Well here's what Ward said, he was like--
You don't do that, man.
No, he said, "Listen, man."
Before I opened the records
he was like, "Listen, man.
"I hope you don't have this.
"I don't know if you have it.
"If you have it just tell me."
That's what he said and then
you joined the conversation
when I'm tellin' it.
I'm like, "Yeah man, I got this one."
But actually he gave me two,
he gave me a used Merle Haggard album
and he gave me a brand new--
Sturgil.
Sturgil Simpson, A Sailor's
Guide To whatever it is.
Which I have.
Which you have.
I actually have the Merle
one too but I lied and said,
"Oh I don't think I have this one."
Oh okay.
So I did feel kinda bad.
All right okay--
So I 50% lied.
'Cause that was the used
one but the new one,
I felt bad that he spent all
that money on a new record.
He did say, "If you've
got it, I'll take it,
"'cause I want this."
Yes he did.
He did say that.
After you told him, after
he kinda saw the look
on your face, he's really
gonna give this back.
My dad is the exact same way by the way.
When he opens a gift--
I got this.
He's like, "This is ugly.
"You picture this on me?"
Like talkin' 'bout clothes at Christmas.
He's notorious.
He'll go through the
trouble of trying it on
to prove to you how bad of a gift it is.
It runs in the family, folks.
I try it on.
It runs in the family.
Just to show you that it ain't me.
I mean look, I'm trying to stand natural.
Wow.
But I just don't
feel right in it.
That's a tough person to give a gift to.
Now the reason my gifts were
so perfect is because your wife
sent me a list.
Yeah I got Low End Theory,
Midnight Marauders.
Haven't listened to 'em yet.
Sufjan Stevens The Avalanche.
Neil Young Harvest Moon.
Oh you gonna list 'em all?
Some of it for the Instagram.
Okay well there's more.
And I got you all new records, man.
They're all plastic-wrapped.
Yeah you went all out.
However, the Steely Dan
album that you recommended
as one of your recs recently--
Aja.
Aja,
you specifically
requested the AB pressing,
not the AA pressing.
Right.
Which they didn't have the AB pressing.
They had some very nice AA pressings
that were plastic-wrapped
and like 30 bucks apiece.
And I don't really--
According to my Reddit research--
Yeah, I looked it up when I was in there.
I looked up the Reddit thread
while I was in the store
'cause I was like, first of all,
what does this mean and is
this what I'm thinking it is.
Apparently different pressings sound
dramatically different
according to Reddit.
And once you read that stuff,
given my personality type,
I can't ignore it.
So I just couldn't have
the AA pressing on my shelf
knowing that Reddit
says that it's inferior.
It's also very rare and you're
not gonna buy it at Amoeba.
Ah.
Because they're like 100 bucks
I think if you can find one.
I think you might be
able to find one on eBay.
It's part of the fun.
I was so excited about it
because the collection aspect
of my life has been fallow for decades.
You know how I like to collect things,
especially as a child.
Mm-hmm.
And still being a 41 year old child.
In Lily's birthday card
to me she was like,
"Happy 41th birthday but I know
you're still a 10 year old.
"Basically."
This is coming from my
16 year old daughter.
True.
Yeah I had to resist,
actually every time I go in Amoeba,
first of all, if you
come to LA you should go
to Amoeba Music 'cause it's,
and there's one in San
Francisco as well right?
It's unlike any other music
store, it's just massive and--
They have concerts in there.
People play live.
Or shows.
They also have books by the way.
I've never been to the
section with the books
and the graphic novels and the games.
I actually went to the game
section so I was like oh,
Link said he wanted me to bring games.
Couldn't find a game to bring
but I bought some books for myself.
But yeah you should go 'cause it's just,
it's a unique experience
but when I was in there,
I thought to myself, I
have to resist that part
of my personality which
looks at the record players
and the speakers and sees that
oh there's a whole world here.
There's a whole world
that you could get into
and you know how I like to get into things
but I'm like well, this one's easy
because Link's already into that so
I can't also get into that.
But I walked through and
I'm so tempted to sit there
and look at these record players--
Did you just admit all the
stuff that you get into
is basically 'cause you know
you're gonna trap me in it?
No no no no.
That's part of it.
No I'm saying that I don't
think it's the kinda thing
that's just like, it's
one thing to be like,
oh, I'm getting into
surfing or off-roading
and something that you can do and be like
oh let's go do that together but--
But you'd trade records.
We could swap records,
you can own half the amount of records.
And plus then you can do
like you did with your lights
and you can be like hey look,
I went out and got lights too.
I got a record player too
but mine's better than yours.
But you can't--
Just like you did
with the lights.
But you can't voice control
a record player.
Google will not know what to do with that.
If you could, then you're gonna get that
so that you can tell me that
you got a better record player.
Also I don't have a spot for it.
Yeah yeah.
My house is set up in kind of a weird way
where I don't have like--
Let it be my thing.
A place.
Come over anytime you want.
I was gonna let it be your
thing until you just told it
that maybe it should be my thing too.
I'm lettin' you off the hook.
I invited you--
I don't wanna spend
the money on that.
I don't wanna pressure you.
Don't let me pressure you.
I'll just give you good records for--
I didn't say let it be
my thing, you know what,
just let it be my thing.
I wanna get into Popsicle fort building.
How 'bout that, I got a spot for that.
Not a lot else to say about the party.
Once I opened all the presents,
in my mind it was pretty much over.
Yeah everybody was still hanging out
and there was a lot of quality
conversation to be had.
Well we did introduce all of our friends
to Jim Bakker's buckets.
Right.
By the end of the--
That's what I served
for dinner.
By the end of the night,
I don't know how we got
on this but by the end--
It was you.
Of the night we brought,
I started talking about it
in a group of people and
by the end of the night
we were gathered around
a television watching
Vic Berger's edits of Jim Bakker's buckets
and they were all just, first
of all, people kept walking in
and every person who would
walk in would not at first
realize that it was an
edit and they thought
that it was original and
so all the weird stuff
that Vic Berger, first of all,
Jim Bakker's buckets
infomercials are weird enough
on their owns, their owns.
If you don't know what it
is, we did a taste test
on the show, you can watch
that or I'll just tell you
that famous '80s televangelist
Jim Bakker has now made
a comeback from scandals
and that's an understatement
to then use fear-mongering of
the apocalypse and the rapture
meaning like the end of the world
and those who are gonna survive it
if they believe the
right things or whatever,
are gonna have to survive off of--
Schlop.
Buckets of schlop
that he sells for like
thousands of dollars.
Well I think you can get
a pretty good deal on 'em.
I mean that was really fun
but it kinda killed my partly honestly.
Whenever we ran out of videos to watch,
everybody was like well, I gotta go home,
and then the only person
that stayed there was Jenny
and me and Jenny hung out
with Christy and Mike,
we hung out for another hour and a half
where she proceeded to summarize the plot
of every Twilight movie to me.
Just talk about opening
up a world you didn't know
if you wanna dip a toe in.
How does such a thing happen?
She's obsessed with Twilight.
I love her to death and I was just like
gettin' a kick out of it.
You know how Jenny will get
on a roll about something.
Well I was talking about
how, Edward Cullen,
or whatever his name is.
Who's Edward Cullen?
Scissor hands.
You talkin' about scissor hands?
No I'm talkin' about the guy
who played the vampire in Twilight.
His real name Robert Pattinson.
Rotten Pattinson.
Rotten.
You know Rotten Pattinson!
He's the new freakin' Batman!
What?
You didn't know this?
This is old news, homey.
Man I work too hard to
know about stuff like that.
Gosh, anyway, summertime,
take your socks off.
Chill out, anyway, I was
talking about Robert Pattinson
being in Batman and then I
knew that would get her all
in a heat wave and I rode
that wave for an hour.
I did not know all the crazy
stuff that happens in Twilight.
What on Earth.
But now you know it
because a woman who's
watched all of 'em just--
She was like I don't
wanna spoil it for ya,
I was like you know what, I kinda do--
Tell me the whole story,
tell me the whole thing.
Yeah.
In 90 minutes.
That's how I ended my
41th, 40, I can't speak.
All right let's talk about the dogs.
I'm done with my birthday, I
can't talk about it anymore.
No 'cause we gotta get to the dogs.
We gotta be linear because as you said,
Jessie ended up leaving from
the party to go directly
to, well she went home, went to LAX,
went to New Orleans with some friends,
left me with the children
for four or five days
and golly, man.
Are you gonna say you
almost killed your dog
when you were in charge of your family?
No the dog thing actually happened before
so we'll come back to that
but I'm just gonna tell you
a little bit about what
it was like to care
for my children and it was especially,
it was complicated by
something that I'm not proud of
that you're gonna, you know what,
you don't even have to say anything.
I'm here to support you.
As I tell this story,
you don't have to say anything.
I know you're gonna wanna
say a lot about this.
I'm not gonna interrupt.
I'm only gonna give a
supportive facial expression.
We filmed something on
Thursday of last week.
And I did what I have
done many, many times
since getting an iPhone 10 and that is,
I got my phone wet.
In fact, I get my phone wet
so often that I regularly film
under the water in my
pool and in my hot tub
because it says that it's water resistant
but I watched a YouTube video
where a guy basically said
you know for all intents and purposes,
the iPhone 10 is waterproof and here's,
and then he does all these tests.
He put it in the bottom of
a pool for like three hours
and he kept testing it
longer and longer and longer
and pulled it up and so
after watching that video,
I came to the conclusion
that it's actually waterproof
but they have to say water
resistant for legal purposes
but you should just treat
it as if it's waterproof.
Well that's all wrong.
Can I say something?
I can't believe you're telling this story
and you're not gonna let me say anything.
Go ahead, you know what, tell your story.
And so I got into a tub with
my phone in my back pocket
and I didn't even think to
check my phone because again,
this is just another day
of my phone getting wet.
This is just what I do with my phone.
It wasn't until like two hours later
when I was like oh I might
need to check my phone
for something that I pulled it up
and it just had the Apple logo on it.
And I was like no, no no no.
No, this can't happen.
What about the video
with the guy in the pool
and the 30 feet and all that?
Well...
It ruined my phone.
Which, do you wanna say something?
Yes.
Can I please?
Say anything you want.
What about the middle of
the story that involved me?
Talking to you about your phone
before you did what you did.
But you didn't even--
Wait you were about
to sit down in the tub.
And we were shooting--
And I said,
"Don't be alarmed.
"I have my phone in my pocket
and I'm gonna sit in the water
"so don't worry, I'm--"
So don't stop the filming.
I'm making the decision to do this.
And then you said, "I
know you're gonna say
"that the iPhone," what you just said.
"I know you're gonna say that
the iPhone is water resistant
"but not waterproof but listen,
"I know it's fine," and
then you said everything
that you said but you left
out that part and I said,
"Listen.
"I don't do that, I don't take that risk."
You're just like, "Yeah I'll
put it down in the bottom
"of the thing and everything,"
so you're the type
of person who you don't trust the phone.
You don't trust, you're missing out, man.
You put it on me.
And well--
You said that.
Because you made it seem
like what I was about
to do was wrong.
You anticipated that I was
gonna judge that you were
doing something stupid.
All I said was, I don't
even think I said anything.
And in one sense you--
You preemptively--
Here's the thing--
Argued with me
and I wasn't even arguing with you.
And in one sense--
And then you killed your phone!
In one sense you have missed out.
All the times that I filmed
underwater up until that point,
it was unreal.
And you know what?
You should look at
some of my--
I haven't said a word
about your phone.
You should look at some
of the videos.
I haven't said a word about it.
So might I say--
But you said,
even if you were to
listen back to your story,
you blamed the phone.
You got to take some of the blame.
Well I am serving a warning
to anyone who has a iPhone 10.
Now according to my son, the
iPhone XR or whatever it is,
he was like, "No Dad, the iPhone 10 is--"
You learn everything
you know from your son.
Yeah well you should listen to him more.
I'm fine with listening to your son.
He was like, "No Dad, the
iPhone 10 is not as waterproof
"as the XR or whatever,"
even though the one
in that frickin' video was an
iPhone 10 because I watched it
and that was what gave me the confidence
that I then took into that tub.
I'm gonna sit down in this tub.
And I wanna acknowledge
that my phone's gonna be
in my pocket, I'm doing it on purpose.
Don't stop the filming because I got this.
I do it all the time.
Now--
And don't argue with me!
You're the one missing out!
That's how it went.
In my defense--
I didn't say nothing.
Hold on, hold on.
Before or after, until now.
In my defense,
what I was saying was is
I am taking responsibility
for the action that I'm
taking so if you tell--
Not when you just retold the story.
No that's what I'm just saying.
You blamed it on the phone.
You blamed it on the
guy who made the video.
Well--
You blamed it on the water.
Can we move on?
I am--
This is fun.
The point, I think maybe for you.
Yeah.
The point of the story is that--
I've been holding this in, man.
The iPhone 10 is not waterproof.
It is water resistant and--
No one ever said it was
waterproof except that guy
in that--
You can push it,
don't push it.
So what this led to is
thankfully my phone was insured
but I don't have Apple
Care so I can't just go
to the store, it was through
the insurance you get
through your carrier right, so,
which means you get it next day.
But there was a problem with the flight.
There was a flight delay
and so I didn't get in
on Friday which means I
had to wait until Monday
which mean I wasn't gonna
have my phone for four days.
The flight that the phone was on?
Yeah 'cause it was
overnight from like Kentucky
or wherever they keep these phones.
And not having my phone
which incidentally we have
the social iPhone here which I was able
to put my SIM card in which is weird
because you can't just take your SIM card
and put it into another phone.
You'll get some texts but
you don't get all texts.
Your phone doesn't work
properly unless you completely
put all your stuff on it--
Submerge it in water?
Yeah you gotta keep it in water.
Right.
Caring for children and
I said this in a tweet
at some point, is mostly
driving them places.
At their age, yeah.
They have to be so many freaking places.
Why do they have to be so many places?
What happened--
They're not quite ready
to get there themselves.
What happened to just being at home,
making fun for yourself?
Why do you gotta have art
camp and basketball practice
and then why you gotta
hang out with your friends?
You know, why can't
you, so driving around,
not having a functioning phone.
My wife got home, she got
home last night actually.
And she walked in the door and she said,
"Why does the house smell like feet?"
And I was like, "Listen,
that is the last thing
"that I'm worried about."
I am just glad that I have
a phone that works now,
that you're back.
They're not dead.
Yeah.
They went to stuff.
We had good times together.
I ended up having lunch
which I never am having lunch
in the middle of the day
with Shepherd but I was able
to do that three days
and we had a great time,
but I don't know, when
she asked the question
about the feet, my honest answer was
I don't know why it smells like feet.
And I don't know why you being here means
it doesn't smell like feet.
I honestly can't, you think it's simple,
you think this thing's--
She's like a
walking odor eater.
You think it's things like
we left socks out, no, everything
was properly disposed of,
which is something about me
and my boys being together
in a home for an extended period of time
that just made it smell like feet.
Stress.
What was it, where's it coming from?
It's not coming from my feet.
I don't even wear socks,
I have wicking shoes.
I think it's just the stress,
the weight of responsibility
being on your shoulders for once.
It just ekes out in like a foot smell.
Man I was just so glad.
Not that, listen, I'm not
trying to give the wrong idea
as if when my wife's in town,
she's the one that worries
about the kids and I don't do anything.
I'm just saying when it's all on you,
I sympathize, man.
The thing was, I wanted
to talk about this,
I wanted to show this
because what I was doing,
thankfully I was able to work from home
and we are currently , look at this.
Look at this, we have what
they call the bound galley
of The Lost Causes of Bleak Creek,
our novel that comes out
in the fall, October 29th.
You can pre-order right
now at BleakCreek.com.
Oh, ad.
So what we're doing
right now is we're going through this
and it's kinda the last
time that we can read it
and edit it before it's completely locked.
You wanna read it right now?
There you go.
And so,
I was able to do that from home.
No pictures in it.
Made it where I could do the
things that I needed to do,
take the kids to where
I needed to take them
and then kinda fill in the gaps with,
oh it's got, oh there's chapter 19.
Close that, people are
gonna zoom in on that, man.
Oh yeah?
People are definitely
gonna zoom in on that.
You're gonna have to blur that, Kiko.
You know what, I'll blur
it, I'll do it myself.
It's my fault.
So I don't know how many
times I've now read the book.
There was a point in which I
was like I've read this book
so many times, obviously
I know every single thing
that's gonna happen
but at this point one of
the things that I'm doing
in going through is making
sure that there's not like
oh, that phrase or that particular word,
that descriptive language was used
and then it was used again
which is something you do,
especially if you're writing
a novel for the first time,
when you're using descriptive
language you may go
to the same places and so
going into those places
and making it and changing it,
that's one of the things I've been doing
but I'm so familiar with it at this point
that I'll see a phrase or I'll
see like two words together,
I'll be like those two words were together
five chapters ago.
Let me go find that and so--
You're gettin' a little too--
Close to it.
Yeah,
you're getting a little
too close to it.
I don't even, it's like--
Now I read it in a day and
a half in a speed kinda way
'cause I also know what's
happening but I read it in reverse
to make sure every word
was spelled correctly.
No I didn't.
Somebody is doing that though by the way.
Because I blurred it out,
really you did blur it out
but I wanna say I did.
I'll read an excerpt from
chapter 19 which is a chapter
that I held up.
He lay there in his Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle boxers
which were still slightly damp.
That's not a complete
sentence, it continues.
It does.
But it was a little bit
of a spoiler if I keep reading.
That is a line in the book in chapter 19.
You were saying you were doing this
and you were building up to something.
No I was saying that was what I was doing.
I was saying I--
So you were able
to be home--
Single parents
who are responsible for
children and have a job--
Like my mom was.
That is, psh, man, I just, again,
I was that for like four days and two
of those days were a weekend.
And I just felt like I
was just gonna go nuts.
I mean, hats off to those of you who are--
Primary caregivers.
Working and raising
children without any help.
It ain't easy.
But I wanna know what
happened to your dog.
You said it was before that.
It was--
I wonder if we're at this point--
The day before we left,
the day before she left.
Are we at this point in
the podcast where it's like
people are mad that we
haven't talked about our dogs?
No no no no no no no.
This is like--
They're fine
with that, right?
This is like the old school
like Charles Trippy and Shay Carl vlogs
where it would say something in the title
and then you'd be like
where the hell is that thing
that they talked about in the title?
Yeah but this is like 40--
There are no rules, just right.
Outback Steakhouse.
I mean I think we've
had a great conversation
except for that part
where you really got on me
about my phone, everything's
been pretty good.
That's a highlight for me.
I really needed that, I've been
holding that in for awhile.
So right before Jessie left, she called me
and she said, "Well,
"I just got a call from a woman
"who said, 'Do you own
a little white dog?'"
And Jessie was like, "Uh, yeah."
She said, "Well, I have it right now."
And for $50,000
you can have her back, no.
That's a good question.
How much would you, well go ahead.
So interestingly here's
what happened, first of all,
Barbara is a homebody.
There's a lot of dogs
that if you open the door,
they bolt for the door
and they'll run, right?
Barbara's never done that, in fact,
sometimes we leave the door
open if we're going down
to the car and Barbara
will just come to the door
if one person's a straggler
and the door is still open,
she'll just come to the front door.
She might walk out onto the
front porch and look at us,
but only if she knows
that she's going to be
in the car does she come
downstairs and get into the car
and then never has she
gone down the driveway.
It's a pretty long driveway
that's kinda steep.
And she's never gone to
the bottom of the driveway.
However, the other day we've
got some guys doing some work
on the house, like redoing
a bathroom and they were,
they had their truck down
at the bottom of the hill
down the driveway, they
didn't drive up the driveway.
And the guy was walking down the driveway
and Barbara just followed
him and got all the way down,
he didn't know that she was following him
and she got all the way
to the bottom and then
at that point, I went outside
and called her back up
and she came back up but at that moment
there was like a look in
her eyes which was like,
there's a whole world beyond this
and it scared me a little bit
but I didn't say anything about it,
I didn't mention it to Jessie.
Well what Jessie did--
Kinda like Jim Carrey at
the edge of that bubble.
Yep.
Haven't seen the movie but I
kinda know what it's about.
The Truman Show, excellent
movie, highly recommend it.
You don't think so?
Oh .
I was laughing 'cause
he had never seen it.
I've seen things.
Anyway, so Jessie was
taking something to the car,
let the door open, went
back inside, shut the door,
and it was in that little
window that somehow,
Barbara had slipped out,
gone down the driveway,
gone down the road.
Gone down the road?
Walked across
an intersection, now,
we live in suburban area
so it's not like she went
across a busy intersection
but she went across an intersection
that was not a four-way stop, like--
I'll put it to you this way.
There aren't painted lines in
the road in your neighborhood.
Right.
But there are intersections.
She could easily be run over by someone
who wasn't paying attention,
and so the story that the woman told was,
she said, "We were--"
That's a long ways away in my mind,
her having never left the house--
A few houses down, I
mean, six houses down.
Two houses down then across the street,
then a couple houses up.
She said, "We were driving on the road
"and we saw her walking.
"I think she was walking
on the side of the road,
"and we stopped 'cause she's not supposed
"to be alone, she's not a coyote."
Which incidentally there are
coyotes in our neighborhood
on the reg and so being
out for that long means
that she could have been
snatched up really quickly.
Oh yeah.
It isn't just
getting run over, it's
coyotes, easily could happen.
I see 'em all the time.
Walking on the street, yeah.
And so she, the woman says, "We saw her,
"we stopped the car, we opened the door
"and she ran and jumped in the car."
She's like you can take
me somewhere faster.
So that is Barbara in a nutshell
which is stranger opens door,
it's like the complete
opposite of what we were told
to do in the '80s when
it comes to strangers.
Stranger opens door, jump in the car.
And the thing is is that
she loves people so much
and she loves strangers.
The fresher you are,
the newer you are to her,
the more she loves you,
which I love that about her,
but she's a liability
and now she understands
there's a whole world of people out there.
She doesn't know about the coyotes.
I can't tell her about the coyotes.
If you walk far enough,
cars stop, open doors
and then you can go anywhere.
Right.
Like cars lead to planes, lead to rockets.
Who knows where she could go.
And first of all, thankfully
we have Jessie's phone number
on her collar which if you
don't have your phone number
on your dog's collar, put it on there.
That's a hot tip.
'Cause even if you chip them--
Who's gonna scan a chip?
There's a delay in that,
you don't know if people
are actually gonna do it,
what are they gonna do with your dog.
Put your phone number on the freakin' dog.
Also get a will.
If we're onto things that--
A dog will?
Obviously know what you should be doing
but you just haven't
gotten around to doing it.
Like what, Barbara's gonna
leave to us if she dies?
If you're a human without a
will, you should have one.
I think everything that Barbara
owns just defaults to us.
I'm talking about human.
Oh okay.
The remainder of Barbara's dog
food goes into a blind trust.
Oh, also like--
And then we had
to figure out what to do with it.
Clean your gutters, you know.
You'll feel better.
So that was my close call with Barbara
and I wanna hear your close call with Jade
and then we can talk
about what we would do
if the unthinkable happened.
I decided to get out, do a little hike.
Me and Christy went for a little hike.
It was gonna be like a one hour thing.
So I took Jade.
I don't take Jade, I took
Jade on a couple of big hikes
but now I started to feel
a little guilty about that
'cause she's so small and
she's not that active.
Yeah.
But a small hike like this
I'll still take her on.
And we're walking in some, this
is in a wilderness park area
and dirt trails and
whatnot and there are signs
like watch out for rattlesnakes
so I was very vigilant
and we walk out and there's
this water shed place
where they've got these dams built up
and then the water will run
and then kinda go trickle over it
but if there's a downpour down the slope,
it won't just erode a
whole bunch of stuff.
It's to prevent the mudslides, yeah.
But you can walk out on these dams
and I walked out on one of
these, I have Jade on a leash,
Christy's behind me, do
not have her on a leash.
She maybe should have me on leash.
Mm.
But she didn't this time.
Never anytime?
You guys don't do the leash thing?
Uh, not in parks.
So we're out on the dam
and as I walk out there
and I see some, no rattlesnakes
but I see some bees
coming out, buzzin' around.
And where there are bees--
There's honey.
Yeah.
What?
What were you gonna say?
Rattlesnakes but yeah, honey, that's--
Yeah it's more correct.
I wasn't thinking about honey,
I wasn't thinking about bees.
I'm like yeah there's bees.
I'm not afraid of bees.
You get real skittish around bees.
Christy gets kinda skittish.
She's like there's bees.
I was like yeah I think there
must be a hive down there
and they were buzzing around at my feet
and going around my ankles.
It never registered to me
that every time Jade sees
a housefly in our house or
like one of those little,
big mosquitoes, it's her
life mission to get it
until she's got it.
That's the most active I see her is
when she's hunting a housefly.
Other than that she just sits in my lap
like she's doing right now.
It crossed my mind until she
starts snapping at some bees
and then she's like shaking
her head and batting her face.
I'm like oh she got stung, we
need to get off this ledge.
I'm like, how stupid can you
be, put my dog in harm's way,
so I take the dog over there,
I think she got stung on the snout.
But they weren't Africanized?
I didn't ask 'em but they weren't--
They weren't aggressive.
They weren't aggressive
because they were buzzing around my legs
just like a normal bee.
They weren't aggressive.
Because that is--
But when she snapped at the
bee, then one stung her,
I believe on her snout.
But that is one thing when you're hiking
in Southern California you
really have to be viligant.
Viligant?
Vigilant, vigilant about--
That's even better.
But if you're in a
village you'd be viligant.
Right.
Yeah, I'm talking about
ignorance is bliss.
I guess that's me on a
hike, but I was looking
for rattlesnakes and that
took all of my energy.
No but I am just saying--
But you're right.
You gotta be prepared,
like do not aggravate
or go close, once you see bees--
Go away.
Go away because they could be Africanized.
Bonehead move on my part--
Then you're in trouble,
they'll chase you for like a mile.
Bees didn't chase us but
a few of 'em were swarming
around Jade and she might
have got stung twice
but definitely once on the snout,
so we walk off the thing
and then we're gonna walk
up the path a little bit
more 'cause I'm like,
I wasn't thinking that
much of it, it's like oh,
she got stung by a bee.
If I got stung by a bee,
I would keep hiking.
And then she lays down.
I'm like this isn't good, she
never lays down on a hike.
We put some water down,
she drank a lot of water
and then come on let's go,
and then she would not keep walking
and I start to get concerned,
Christy's already concerned.
She's got good intuition,
she's like "Yeah,
"this isn't good, pick her up."
And I pick her up, she's very floppy,
just putting her head down,
I started to feel horrible
that I led her to this bee patch.
They're like strawberries
I guess and then I'm like--
Found a bee patch.
Christy's like
let's turn around.
We gotta get back to the car,
she might need treatment,
and we walk a little
bit and I put her down
and this has been like five
minutes since she was stung,
we had decided to turn
around and she threw up.
And then I'm like she could be
having an allergic reaction.
Is there any swelling?
There was no visual of
swelling on the snout
or anywhere, just lethargy,
vomiting, and floppiness.
And I'm starting to get scared
but I'm kinda in denial,
I'm like I don't wanna
think the worst here
but Christy's like her
throat can swell up,
she could die.
If she's having an allergic
reaction so we're walking down,
we're calling the vet and
Googling as we're walking,
I'm carrying her, she's like
a lifeless little fur ball
and we're getting scared and they said,
"Well the vet's in surgery,"
and Christy's like,
"Well, can you recommend
somewhere else that we can go?"
There was another vet that
we used to go to in town
and she's like we'll
call 'em and it was like,
no they're in surgery as well.
I'm like dang, vets like to
do this afternoon surgery.
That's where the big money's at.
The vet agreed to come out
of surgery and take a look
so we take her there and
the stinger for like,
if it stays in there can
continue to pump venom
even after the bee's gone away.
I learned that you should
try to get rid of the stinger
but it wasn't there, I think
she batted it away initially
but she was having an
allergic reaction because
the way she was acting and vomiting
and they gave her
Benadryl and just told her
she's gonna be really
sleepy and it was like,
there was no sign of
swelling so they were like,
"Are you sure she was stung by a bee?"
We're like yes, definitely but,
I didn't allow myself to believe
that this could be a life
or death situation but I was
certainly hiking very fast
back down to the car
to get her over there.
So it was pretty scary
but they put us at ease
and how to talk to the vet
and then she was just very lethargic
for the next 24 hours
because of the Benadryl
but everything's fine now,
she's eating and drinking fine
and look, she's right here.
But she has a specific allergy to bees?
Or this would happen
to any dog of her size?
No they said it was an allergy
for her to react that way.
I love you too, she gave me a kiss.
She's still a little,
it's been like 48 hours,
she's still a little bit mopey
but she's kinda mopey anyway.
Look at her.
She seems embarrassed.
It wasn't your fault,
baby, it was my fault.
I shouldn't have let you
into that patch of bees.
I should have known better
and then but you talk
about hot tip, he said,
"Where did you go?"
and we told the vet and he said,
"Well you need to come back
"and get a rattlesnake venom
vaccine," which I was like,
"I didn't know this
existed," and they were like,
"Yes, rattlesnakes are really bad.
"There's a lot more rain in
LA now, they're coming out.
"Dogs are coming in from
dog parks getting bit
"by rattlesnakes in dog parks and dying."
Hold on, you can get a rattlesnake--
A rattlesnake vaccine.
Vaccine?
Can I get one?
He said that, well, he's a vet,
he doesn't give it to humans.
I didn't ask that question
so I don't know the answer
but he said that all it
does is gain you time,
like an hour to get them to a vet.
That's what the vaccine does.
So if you're in an area with rattlesnakes,
there is such a thing
as a rattlesnake vaccine
and it gains them precious
time to get them to a vet,
I'm talkin' an hour.
'Cause their bodies can't take it.
If a small dog gets bit by a rattlesnake--
I'm just not gonna take her out anymore.
I think it kinda--
Keep her in a bubble man.
Keep her in a bubble.
It's a little different
than a child, it's like, our
children you gotta let 'em out
into the world and educate them about--
'Cause they gotta take
care of themselves someday.
The rattlesnakes and make their
own place smell like feet.
You're gonna take care of her.
You can baby her all you want.
That's right, that's why I walk her up
and down the stairs, put her in the bed,
I take her out of the bed.
She'll jump out of the
bed now and she'll beg
for water in the middle of the night.
Right.
And so I start puttin' water
in our bathroom upstairs 'cause I live
in a huge frickin' mansion.
Yeah takes forever to get--
It's a long ways down there to shoes.
Right, getting to your closet.
And water.
Was that the same podcast?
Are we still in the same podcast?
Yeah yeah yeah, I mean one might argue
that I should encourage
Barbara to go out on her own
and go and be with another
family because she's gonna have
to do that one day but she's
not gonna do that one day.
She is not, but she is gonna die.
I would have been--
After she lives
her very long life.
I thought about, I love Jade so much,
I think I've said this.
I frequently in my most
tender moments of snuggling,
I just instinctively think
about when she's gone
because it's like 15 years,
maybe less, if I'm lucky,
she's gonna pass on.
She's gonna go to doggy heaven, or hell.
She may go to doggy hell.
I don't know what the criteria
is for these decisions.
Yours is definitely going to hell.
But she's so lazy.
She's mean though, she's mean.
She's mean to other--
Not to me.
Barbara's very nice to other people.
She's going to doggy heaven.
It's not like the woman who picked her up
wasn't a literal angel or God.
It was just a neighbor of yours.
That woman has no bearing
on whether your dog goes
to heaven or hell but I
find myself thinking--
You haven't lost a dog
as an adult, I have.
'Cause you haven't had a dog in so--
If Jade would have died from the honeybee,
I literally thought when
we got her back home,
I was like if that would have happened,
I would have been out of
commission for at least
a solid week of I'm not
leaving the house, I'm not--
I don't believe that.
I think you would be in
mourning for a long time
but I don't think you
would be like I can't come
into work for a week.
I think you probably would--
That's what I thought.
That's what I feel but--
I'm not saying
it would be easy.
I do think you're right
that I would say I gotta get out of here,
I gotta try to--
Now in the Book of Mythicality,
I talk extensively about this,
about the McLaughlin
family dog curse and how--
Right.
Growing up we had two dogs
run away and then as an
adult I've had two dogs die
and then we went for well over a decade
without having a dog
because of this curse.
Now Barbara, a few things
about Barbara, number one,
she's been around significantly
longer for any other dog
and she's only been around
for like three years or so.
Mm-hmm.
Our relationship with her
is way different and better
than the relationship that
we had with the other dogs.
I mean Merle, our first dog as a couple
died in the first year and then Gypsy,
our second dog who...
No, maybe it was the other way around.
Gypsy was the first dog.
She was a rescue that I
literally found on the side
of the road and I rescued and kept.
'Cause she didn't have her owner's number.
I couldn't call her old owner's number
so I just kept her for myself.
No but she was like an
abandoned puppy in the woods
and she made it like a year and then died
and when she died, Jessie
was pregnant at the time
and when she died that
night, she died at the beach.
She got ran over at the beach.
And we just sat and laid
in the bed and cried.
And then the rest of
the trip was kinda like
clouded by this.
Mm-hmm.
And then there would be times
over the next couple months
where we would think about her.
I would think about
her and I would get sad
maybe almost cry or get teary-eyed.
And how was the quality of
relationship that you had
with Gypsy compared to Barbara now?
Not even close.
Right.
So--
'Cause I think you
approach dogs differently.
There's all kinds of things
that are different like
it's been a longer period of time.
Barbara is, she's a special dog.
She's the most affectionate
dog I've ever met
and we have our stretch and
snuggle time in the morning
when I get on my back and do my stretches
and she snuggles with
me and then of course,
our kids--
I didn't observe,
I don't recall observing
a connection like you have
with Barbara that--
It would be devastating.
I think there's a trope-ish
stage of life thing that--
For sure.
That dads go through when--
For sure, I never had a daughter.
My only daughter is Barbara.
Okay.
But and I think--
And that was difficult
but you know how much more
difficult it's gonna be
if Barbara passes.
It would be devastating
but and listen, there is
no comparison in my mind,
there's absolutely no comparison.
Obviously losing a child would be,
that's the worst thing that could happen.
I can't imagine anything worse than that.
That is the worst thing
that can happen to you.
And they're not even,
I don't think they're
in the same ballpark by any means
because with a dog, you
kinda know this dog is,
like you said, Jade's existence
and Barbara's existence
in your family has reached
a stasis that it will
basically be at until she
starts to get older and feebler.
But she's pretty much who she's gonna be.
She's fully expressed and
she's gonna live a maximum
of something teen years.
Right.
And you know that that's gonna happen.
So if it happens earlier,
it would be devastating
but it's still not a drastic upheaval
in what you're planning for your dog
in the way that you plan for
another human in your life.
And so I think that there's
a period of mourning
but then you're kinda like
okay, I'm gonna get another dog.
I don't wanna downplay the mourning
but I do think that...
I'm interested in feedback so #EarBiscuits
but I think...
And I may have mentioned
this, there are times
that I think about getting a second dog
and I do think that that's part of,
I'm interested in that
being part of the strategy,
if at a certain point in
introducing a second dog
so there's like overlap,
there can just be overlap.
So it's like if Jade's nine,
not too old.
Not like okay, I got
like a year or something,
I gotta try to, more of
an overlap than that.
I kinda feel like that
would help a little.
But I could be totally wrong,
I've never been through this.
I think it does help
'cause we've got friends
who had dogs that, weren't Max
and Ruby brother and sister?
Yeah.
And our friend Nick had two
dogs he was very attached to.
And he lost one.
He ended up,
they lost both of them eventually.
I mean losing the second
one, I don't know,
I'd have to ask him what was worse but--
I definitely think that
being able to be like,
we still got a dog.
To go from having a dog to
having no dogs I think would be,
or a pet, obviously this
also applies to cats,
those of you who can make those kinds
of emotional connections to cats.
The same thing applies, in fact, my son--
Very magnanimous of you--
My son has a friend
whose cat recently died and it was,
cat had been around for a very long time
and the family had a very difficult time.
Lincoln had a friend who
came to school talking about
how his dog died and everyone was sad
and Lincoln cried for his friend and then,
turns out the dude was joking.
And then a few weeks later,
his dog actually died.
Well yeah, that's what happens to you.
Joke about your dog
dying, it's gonna happen.
Just like you said--
'Cause of The Secret.
Manifest.
Yeah you manifest.
Full circle, that was still this podcast.
We've been on quite a journey, Rhett.
Wow he cried for a friend,
that is a high level of empathy.
Yeah.
Hold on in what context?
I'm crying right now.
He talked about the dog
dying and he started crying
in front of him or later, he was--
He teared up.
That's unusual.
Yeah, well, it's not unusual for Lincoln,
I think that's just, you
know, given his connection
with Jade and--
I'm not saying it's unusual,
I'm saying it's unusual for
a teenage boy to be told
about someone else's
dog dying and then cry.
I'm saying as a father of a teenage boy
who knows a lot of teenage
boys, I'd say that's unusual.
I'm saying it's a good
thing but it's not normal.
It's good, it's like you
would want other kids
to have that level of empathy.
Yeah I'm glad he did it
especially just so his friend
could turn around and stamp on it
and say he was just joking.
I'll never cry for your dog again, jerk.
I did ask him, so when his
dog really did die, did you--
He laughed, naturally.
Yeah it's like assuming
that he's joking, it's like,
and I can have a dark sense of
humor so I reserve the right
to joke about Jade dying.
That doesn't, you know--
And I think that's okay.
I think it's okay and I
think it demonstrates--
I think maybe it's part
of my coping mechanism.
It might be a coping mechanism
but it also demonstrates
that there's a fundamental
difference between a relationship
with an animal and a
relationship with a human.
I could joke about anybody
dying and then feel the,
I'm not gonna do it currently
but I joke about death.
And I think it puts it in its place.
But there are lots of
people who talk about their,
people who don't have
children who have pets--
I guess I'm taking up for
Lincoln's friend, I don't know.
No there are people who don't
have children but have pets
and sometimes we'll
start talking to people
who have children and
talking about their pets
as if they're children,
as if they can relate
to having children
because they have a pet.
Pets and children ain't
nearly the same thing.
But you can get an inkling of that.
I mean I'm not gonna say
that there's not some--
No you can't.
Yes you can.
I highly disagree.
Having a child and having a pet are not
in the same ballpark.
Okay you're responsible for another being.
Yes that's true, but--
I'm not minimizing what
happens if you've got a pet.
I'm saying what you're
saying is true except that
that there is a connection.
I think you can lose
something precious to you
that's not even living and it in some,
I wouldn't then access
that conversationally
with someone who's lost a child.
I'm not saying that, I'm not minimizing,
what I'm saying is that for those people,
this is unrelated to the thing dying.
What I'm saying is is if
you're in a conversation
with somebody who's got, you're like man,
I had to, it was kinda crazy,
my son just went through a
really difficult time at school
with blah blah blah and they're like yeah,
my dog has hip dysplasia.
It's like they're not in the same, okay,
I'm not saying that's easy,
but it's not like having a
child go through something.
It's different, man.
As someone who's got children
and pets, it's different.
All I'm saying is I think
people who don't have kids
can then, they can access
empathy through an experience
that they have with loving a pet.
Yeah I don't have a daughter like I said.
I'm the one who said a second ago
that Barbara's my daughter.
That's all I'm saying.
I tell her she could be
anything she wants to be.
She's gonna go to doggy college,
she's gonna have a great doggy career.
Are you going to, what do
you think about the overlap
in order to prepare, you know--
It's not worth it.
Hmm.
I don't want to deal with two dogs.
Plain and simple.
Barbara is--
I don't wanna divide the love.
She's attached to humans.
Well that's not a problem,
you got three kids,
you didn't divide the love between them.
Yeah I did.
No I just don't--
I don't know the
answer to that.
When we travel and
figuring out what to do,
if we're gonna take 'em on
a walk, adding an extra dog
into the mix is same reason
I've only got two kids
and not three, so I wanna minimize that.
I want to enjoy the
benefits of having a pet.
And then start over afterward.
And then yeah.
And maybe take a relatively
long break before the next one.
I don't know.
Well--
Depends on what stage
of life I'm in.
I think that makes me
think that maybe I should,
I shouldn't get another dog
in order to not go through
the pain of losing one.
You should get another dog
if you want another dog, period.
Yeah, you shouldn't use
a dog as a death bridge.
And some people think you
should get another dog,
depending on the breed, for
the companionship of the dog.
Like I said--
Our dogs,
neither one of them
need that, that's clear.
They have plenty of--
Our dogs do not know that they're dogs.
So getting another dog would be like
what is this dog doing here?
You know?
Why did you get a dog?
Did you get me a dog?
What made you guys think
that we needed a dog?
Is what our dogs would say.
When you said that I
pictured a meme of Barbara
with another dog.
Yeah there's a good
meme of that somewhere.
Yeah.
It's funny.
Somebody do that, make a meme.
But given the time that we've taken--
Yeah let's wrap it up.
We need to hear your rec.
Oh my gosh, my rec is...
I look for an app to
catalog my record collection
on my phone because now that
I'm back into collection mode,
I wanna know what that
was and I went around
to a bunch of cute different
apps and then I came back
to the one that everyone talks about
on the vinyl Reddit
thread and that's Discogs.
Which is kind of a marketplace for buying
and selling of records
but I just use it to,
it's a way for me to carry
my record collection with me
at all times.
See look, I can just scroll.
Well I guess the pictures don't show up
if you're in airport mode but
the pictures usually show up.
And sometimes when I get
bored and I wanna feel good
about myself I look at
my record collection
and I just kinda scroll it.
Can you click on that--
It boosts my chi.
Can you click on that and
would this be sacrilegious--
I don't even know what that means.
If you clicked on that
and you could play them on your phone
like the digital version of those songs
or does that go against the whole point?
I think you're describing Spotify.
No it cannot do that.
No but if you wanted
to be like, oh this is
my record collection.
This is the songs that I own.
Oh I want you to hear this
song but we're not currently
at my record player.
That feels like you, yeah,
you could just go one app over
but if you wanna experience
the album as intended--
Look at that.
Yeah you can't do that.
But you can make a wishlist
and then you can buy--
How often do you listen
to your record player?
I'm trying to do it more often
now that I got these records.
Because every time I've
come over to your house,
you're just playing Spotify.
Yeah 'cause it goes
throughout the whole house.
It's a different, you have
to have a listening session.
It takes discipline and
a little bit of planning
and then, I'll do it
when I'm drinking coffee
on a weekend morning.
Mm.
And I've started trying
to do it like sometimes during
dinner we'll play a record
but then in the middle
of it I gotta get up
and flip the record, but all of that--
You need a jukebox.
All of that jukebox, all
of that's part of it.
And it's the negative, the
things that you could point out
as negative aspects of record listening,
I'm just trying, I think
you can make 'em positives.
It's not about the convenience,
it's about the art.
And if you just wanna get a little boost
even when you're apart from
your record collection,
you can get Discogs and if
you're doing some crate diggin',
you won't buy doubles.
Do you feel a noticeable,
tangible difference
between the vinyl songs
and the digital songs?
Nope and red wine is red
wine but I, you know,
I know, I aspire to be able
to have an opinion on red wine
and I kind of, and I
actually did do an AB test.
Yes, it sounds different.
If you walked into the room--
It's warmer.
You would know which one
was which.
I think I would, yeah.
Yeah, on the same speakers.
'Cause you'd see
the record spinning, you would--
Yeah you can tell a difference.
You can tell a difference,
but I think being able
to tell the difference, I'm
not gonna say that makes me
a cooler or better person but
I am kind of implying that.
Do you listen to records
and drink red wine
at the same time?
I haven't.
Hmm.
I should.
But you're gonna be drinking
like Barefoot wines.
Charles.
Oh.
I was gonna say Charles Schwab.
What's two-buck Chuck, Charles what?
Charles, Chuck, I don't know.
Charles.
It's the cheapest wine
you can get.
I thought when you said
Barefoot I thought you literally
were talking about because
my feet were so sweaty
from wearing shoes all day without socks.
You're barefoot drinking
Barefoot wine listening to--
Yeah.
Something barefoot.
Barefoot Mountain Boys.
Barenaked Ladies, you got--
Charles Shaw.
That's my rec, get some Charles Shaw,
get your records, Discogs.
#EarBiscuits.
Thanks for letting us
shoot the breeze with ya.
Yeah don't give us any
crap about waiting so late
to answer the question, okay?
And don't give Rhett any crap about
the thing about his phone.
That's right.
The thing I didn't tell you
is that the replacement phone
that I got is messed up.
Not because I put it in water
'cause I'm not doing that again.
Because--
Why are you not
doing that again?
Well the way insurance
works is they give you
a refurbished phone.
Everything about it seems
completely normal and new,
like you see that screen,
there's not a scratch on it.
The face ID will not
activate which is a problem
that is usually a hardware problem.
So every time you look
at your phone and try
to get it to activate, you
think about that moment
when you told me, "I've got this."
And I'm gonna have to do it again.
You don't have to say anything.
This is one of those situations
where I learned my lesson
without you having to say anything at all.
Now that you've said that--
You just couldn't resist.
Now that you've said
that, I can let it go.
We'll keep resisting.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.